we are back with the one and only Brooke
Shields and joining us is the executive
producer of the documentary and one of
the most brilliant and funny women on
planet Earth Ali Wentworth
I am the one and only Allie Wentworth it
doesn't surprise me that because you're
getting are you getting a two shot of my
face next to Brooks because that's mean
oh my how about like
um I you have a real girl pack like
you're you have a bond we
yeah
we do but it's also because
you know you're strong and very full of
humor and I I are you drawing like very
it's it's a there's a kinship for sure
with that but there's also something
that happens that people don't seem to
highlight
um is that she and we lift each other up
we like we celebrate the women in our
lives we're not we're not trying to
press them down so that we can be
superior like it we're not catty like
that's what real female friendships
that's what women should be like in town
yeah
but that's true yeah this is this is
women should be lifting each other up in
every category whether you work at a
library or you're a fisherwoman or you
know you're running for a seat in Senate
women should be I mean I know it's scary
for you men I get it but it's uh it's
something we should all be doing and by
the way I wanted to say you were talking
about like you guys growing up you were
also growing up in a culture where there
were not that many famous people so
famous people were gigantic and now we
live in a world where you know you have
influencers our daughters you know on
social media and I think it's really
important and one of the messaging with
this film is like you can you can do all
your fun stuff on social media but don't
turn yourself into a product which is so
easy to do in this day and age you know
what I mean and have who you are as a
person be your strength but also when
they ask kids you know if you ask kids
today like what do you want to be they
say famous
it's not like oh I want to be an actress
or I want to be a this no they want to
be famous and like that that sort of
Disconnect is so dangerous
so dangerous and it's coveting the wrong
things how I couldn't agree more and yet
we were lucky in that sense that we had
it so it's easy for us to say that
because we got the privilege of being
that but you were a pure human being
through it all I know you I know you're
intention anymore
but it makes a difference for all of us
looking and I have no objectivity on my
own life but it's like you really are
the living example of you were at the
eye of the storm you were the storm
itself you were the everything but you
were a very good person who did not seek
the wrong things from this life and in
this world and that's incredible but you
know what else also I think possibly
because we were so young we are
yeah exactly you know what I mean I
don't know how much closer we can get
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign